in the early days of flight engineers
relied on building materials like wood
and canvas to build their planes the
Wright brothers worked tirelessly to
reduce the weight of their aircraft to
allowed to get off the ground they use
woods with high strength to weight
ratios like spruce and ash to build a
frame but it needed to be reinforced
with steel wire to prevent the frame
from bending under flight loads the
flight services were covered in
lightweight fabric to provide a smooth
aerodynamic surface but one of their
greatest innovations was the
construction of their engine no engine
existed at this time that matched their
power to weight requirements so they
went about inventing their own they were
the first in history to use aluminium as
a building material for an engine using
it to construct their crankcase they
even painted the engine black so their
competitors couldn't see the engine was
built with aluminium aluminium makes up
8% of the Earth's crust despite that it
used to be one of the world's most
expensive materials it is a difficult
material to refine Napoleon had
envisioned the lightweight metal as the
perfect material for weapons and armor
but became frustrated with the
difficulty of the refining process
finally giving up he had a small supply
of aluminium melted down and made into
cutlery in plates to serve his most
esteemed guests when the lower ranks
were resigned to the last expensive gold
pieces it wasn't until the 1880s that
methods capable of mass producing the
material were developed in a few short
years aluminium went from being the most
expensive metal on earth to one of the
cheapest dropping in price from $1200
per kilo in 1852
to just $1 per kilo at the start of the
20th century this paved the way for the
Wright brothers to use the material in
the Wright Flyer but the material the
Wright's used was very different to the
aluminium alloys we see today despite
the availability of aluminium planes
true our World War One continued to use
wood and canvas as their primary
building materials because the aluminium
that was available back then was weak
and malleable an accidental discovery of
a new heat treatment by the German
scientist Alfred Wilm led to the
development of an aluminium alloy strong
enough for structural use alfred was
trying to recreate the effects of quench
hardening that a scene with iron alloys
like steel you see this process a lot in
the awesome man-at-arms series after
heating the steel between 700 and 900
degrees
they'll quench the blade in oil or water
this rapidly cools the steel which
causes a crystalline structure called
martensite to form
is much stronger than the crystal
structure that would form if it was
allowed to cool slowly but this
technique does not work with aluminium
as the story goes one Friday afternoon
alfred was testing a new alloy of
aluminium he had developed containing
about 4 percent copper he followed the
steps for quench hardening he heated the
metal up and allowed the heat to evenly
distribute throughout the material he
then removed the metal from the heat and
quenched it rapidly cooling it
he then tested the material but it
showed no real sign of improvement
becoming frustrated he left the lab
leaving the remaining samples resting at
room temperature over the weekend to his
amazement when he returned the following
Monday he discovered the remaining
samples had grown stronger Alfred Wilm
had just accidentally discovered age
hardening process that would make
aluminium the world's new Wonder
material so what happened here why did
the alloy get stronger over time to
understand this we need to look at the
metals crystalline structure this is a
single aluminium atom now it is joined
by more atoms they don't just arranged
randomly they form irregular patterns
with a repeating structure aluminium
forms a repeating crystal structure
called face centered cubic which looks
like this and it defines many of the
properties of the material one of these
properties is the direction it most
easily deforms for example this crystal
structure deforms most easily along this
plane this is called a slip plane let's
look at a 2d cubic structure like this
it can easily slip in these parallel
directions so for forces flight here
with sufficient force each atom will
shift down and the material will be
permanently deformed but this material
is pure aluminium what happens when we
swap some of these aluminium atoms for
copper copper atoms are slightly larger
than aluminium and they create internal
strain when fitting into the aluminium
crystal lattice when the alloy was
heated the copper spread evenly through
the material and the quenching process
trapped the copper in these locations in
these positions the copper atoms do not
provide much strength but over time they
will begin to coalesce to form these
secondary crystal structures within the
main crystal structure this is called a
second phase the second phase particles
create barriers to deformation for
deformation to occur and much greater
force is needed in the following years
Alfred perfected this process figuring
out the ideal aging temperature in time
he dubbed this new material German and I
was used to build the world's first
all-metal aircraft the Junkers jae-won
the impact is aged hard in aluminium
odd cannot be understated it completely
transformed our world prior to its
introduction plane trains were all built
with rigid truss structures like this
with aluminium at their disposal
Engineers could create a new flight
structure the monocoque and
semi-monocoque with these frames the
aluminium skin forms an integral part of
the plane strength not just being used
as a streamlined flight surface these
new techniques freed up space within the
planes and allowed spacious passenger
planes to be developed assuring in a new
era of travel in the world 13% of the
world's aluminium is used by the energy
sector even though copper is a better
conductor all main overhead power lines
use aluminium as the conducting material
to carry the same current as a copper
wire an aluminium wire needs to be 1.5
times thicker and even then it is still
2 times lighter this decreases the load
on pylons and allows the spans between
them to increase dramatically this saves
vast amount of money on construction 23%
of aluminium is used in construction the
Empire State Building was the world's
first skyscraper to use the material
extensively its corrosion resistance and
lightness made it the perfect material
for external framing and roofing it's
clear to see without this material the
world we see today will be very
different and only recently has
aluminium started to see competition
from competent materials like carbon
reinforced plastics but that's a topic
for another day thanks for watching this
video was sponsored by the vlogbrothers
I didn't even have to put this message
at the end but I don't believe in
getting something for nothing so please
go check out scishow latest video the
physics of the roller coaster and
consider subscribing if you have any
questions feel free to ask in the
comments and if you'd like to support
this channel the links from my patreon
Instagram Facebook and Twitter accounts
are below
you